[music]
how digital do we want to live
how do we stay healthy for as long as possible
[music]
how can the environment be protected
and what will the europe of tomorrow
look like [music] questions of the future like these concern
us all and  researchers
all over europe especially
together we work on solutions and
answers
the european research area briefly fr
ensures the right
framework conditions and the necessary research
freedom
in the effeff user talks give
researchers insights into their specialist area
and respond to theirs in direct exchange with
the audience  questions in the
first episode we go on a journey
from the arctic permafrost to
the lofty heights of monte simone and
find out what is
being researched in europe and what innovations are
still awaiting us have fun
[music] hello everyone
imagine
it would be climate protection  request concert what
would change in europe then
we would be talking about that today  speaking at the
bfr future talk today we are talking about
nothing less than the most important topic of
our time, the topic of climate protection
and also about the topic of adaptation to
climate change and ef er we have already
heard that stands for european
research area and today we
actually have something very special  special because
we have really excellent
researchers from
europe who are talking about their work today and
answering questions and all of this also
live, which means you can
ask questions at home and you should
probably do that because
you don't get the chance that often and  where
are we here we are on the balance 1
way and everything here this is an
event that the bmbf
launched the ff future talk to talk about
all the great things that are happening in research in europe
and why
it is so important  is that you work
together and that's a very
nice thing and i'm not
alone here s  but i also have two
excellent researchers are guests here
for a panel discussion once
daniela jacob she is metrology director of the
climate service center germany's des
garrigues and also
chair of the german climate committee of the
german committee for
sustainability research and co-
chair of the science platform
of science  form of government
sustainability also astrid
kinderschar she is chairwoman of the
german climate consortium with author of
the icgc
whom many probably already know
when it comes to climate and also head
of the institute for energy and
climate research at the research center
jülich and my name is jakob i am
on the one hand  science youtuber from the
youtube channel waking up and
i'm also doing research at the university of cologne as part of
a doctorate on the topic of learning
with videos and maybe
one or the other person will know me from the
tv of 5 gegen jauch or the
smaller ones maybe vo  m tigers club
and the topic of sustainability and
climate change is a really exciting
topic and that's why I
'm happy that I have the opportunity
to learn a lot about it today and the
first block of topics we want to deal with today
is the question of where
do we stand  actually in
climate research where are we right now and
we have someone who
can tell us a lot about it because
i don't know how you are doing but
for me sometimes you get
something from studies you hear it from the gcc
and  it's all often very complex and
you need a lot of effort
to work on it and the next project that
tries to do something about it is
the senses project and we've now brought
cornelia on
board for the ground breaking the waves complex
and stakeholder
implement the transformation needed
to  understand war's information
leak information from htc or studies and
climate change and
distance infor  mation
exchange
[music]
of
what a question of
the
[music]
weekend
looking into
you have thought of studies
of information about small change
that
everybody knows about the chair is us
very good information processing
for action
[music]
center
projects from  how many country phase
so
invites the family
to the east ring i have the expertise
transition scenarios spot in stockum in
borken has the
experts
in austria
infection or 20 points information
connect
very nice nice to see that people are
working together for big problem and
take much  for sharing the
experience with a
look at the project
on
different countries working together or
for the big problem climate change and
this one is what about technologies
built innovation spot casual games
climate change who before
julian hankiewicz
project is landmark project
excellence market would
[music]
how do you do
co
[music]
international
is
[music]
[  Applause]
the culture
great example of working together
was certainly problematic informations
considered so simply
working together is very promising
when it comes to this huge problem
as a single country you ca
n't do it all and that's why it would
actually be for  I ask myself the question you
have now heard of projects that
somehow I also always find
hope because these are concrete
projects you can see there are great developments
here it is also great to see a lot of
people working together across
borders now my question to
you would be how it is  that's where we
are in europe right now with research on the
subject of climate protection but also on the subject of
climate adaptation to climate change
where are we right now i do
n't know the beginning would like to start on this topic
i know maybe about climate protection
and then climate adaptation would
then  come back take over i think
an element i like to emphasize
what has now also been mentioned here is of
course that
climate research is extremely internet extremely
interdisciplinary, which means that in order
to be successful you have to bring the most
diverse disciplines together
it is so that in the last few
decades a lot has happened in
terms of the different ones, so to speak
to enable the exchange between disciplines also to know that we
have developed a common vocabulary
there is certainly a lot at the level of
understanding climate change,
especially with regard to model development
on climate change what future
development do we expect to have improved significantly
has european research had the
most significant impact this is of
course a global research
community in which we operate but
the european one plays an important
role
it is  but also so that it is clear
which processes and which aspects we
still insufficiently understand
both in terms of basic research
and in terms of how to
translate this knowledge that in
case of doubt one already has
the details so that one can actually apply it in the climate models
climate models are normally constructed in such a way that calculations are carried out
in
relatively rough spatial and
temporal structures, i.e.
everything that
happens faster on time scales
or that happens in a very spatially resolved manner
is not trivial to implement, so
that the step towards, so to speak, the
next generation of computers in
order to be able to make improvements  an
important thing is of course
that the observation side what do
we know about climate change simply
because we can observe it in our environment
has changed significantly we have better and better
options both from the ground and
from space observations e.g  u we
have been making observations for a long time
so that our
statements can become more concrete and
also the derivations and deductions
from the data, so to speak
very
complex problem there is
actually still a lot to do and especially when it
comes to somehow developing climate models they have to
they need a
lot of time so that they become
more precise and above all
can calculate this complex field at all
which has so many factors are  if i
understand that correctly yes i
think you can sum it up like this in the
first woman jakob you
would like to add something yes i think
especially when we are talking about climate models
then we have to think
back to the fact that these are not
climate forecasts  that means we
don't just talk about the weather,
we talk about h  ere
about the long periods of time, we are
ultimately talking about what could be in store for us in the next 20, 30,
40, maybe 100 years
and, just as the projects
have shown, to also give the local
users data and
information to those affected on site  to
be able to adapt to what you have to adjust to
, under certain circumstances we must, of course, understand
these
so-called climate simulations, these
projections into the future
, and i think at this
point we have to say that it is
almost impossible to do this alone with one nation
, because the climate models themselves also have
that  uncertainties so it's not
just about calculating with these climate models
not doing much climate protection then
the earth's climate warms up less
than if I do less climate
protection these are these so-called if,
then relationships that I'm always happy to
bring in
it's also about the
formulation of these models, of course
even with some u  There are some uncertainties
and we have therefore started to
cover the entire possible development space, I think in the
community with many different
models,
so these
uncertainties that we know and that
was exactly what Astrid just
said, like us, so to speak, the
information  we can translate the
observation data into our
understanding and
then feed it into this model to improve it
that's one side that's
very, very important, which then
takes back more and more uncertainties,
but the other side is stuff like that is
nothing other than mathematical
formulas these are the physical
processes so the raindrop falls on
the ground and the ground gets wet
you can convert that into a physical
law then you can pour that into
a mathematical formula and
then program it
really isn’t that much more and there’s always that too
still unsure in the system
We try to tackle these by
saying that we want as many models as possible,
which in principle simulate the same climate
developments, but
which are all a
bit different in origin, and
then we also come up with these
bandwidths around the uncertainty
that is inherent in this methodology  so one of the
uncertainties is to get out of it and
you can say that in europe
we actually have very, very good,
very good conditions because we have
ten fifteen different centers in
europe that develop such models
independently but in cooperation
, so they are not all the
same  they are also different
types some are more similar than others
but together they cover the
whole continent or even the
whole world and so they
give us this little uncertainty that lies in the methodology gives us a chance
to grasp it and i think
you need a special one for that  the cooperation
because one nation alone could
not do that we in germany i think we
have two three global climate models and
also two more three rules all but
we need something like 30 40 worldwide
and we also have them if you say in
europe i might say ten  15 that
means the connection from the national
research in the europe in the
european area and then in the
international is extremely important for this
assessment of some areas in the
small army of climate research
that actually means it would
n’t work at all if you didn’t have so many
institutes  then
bring your results together and with that
you then mark off an area i think for
many people who are not involved in this
research i think it is also included for me
it is sometimes very
complex to
understand what the statements behind it
are and since we mean now  ask well
what kind of challenge or what
big problems do you see  just when
you know of course climate change is a
huge problem as well as a very,
very big problem there are concrete
problems that are currently becoming visible from the
data where you are then also actively
trying to find solutions for so
maybe you can first say we
have in the  done a lot in the last few decades
so the statements you are
now getting from climate research
about how the climate
could change in the coming decades are quite robust
and they are also so that no matter
which model you came from, they
are all going in the same direction  but
it is possible that one model says
there is 10 15 percent more precipitation
and the other would say there are more like
2 just
to show you the uncertainties there are
no longer the points that one
model says it is raining more and  the
other says it's raining less that
means through research over the last i
would say 10 15 years these have changed
the changes that are coming to us
are developed in such a way that we can learn to deal with
them that is one area
there are of course still major
questions here one is how
exactly is the climate changing on site, i.e.
the local we know quite well how things
are in regions  changes region sizes
like the lüneburg heath or the eifel
or the magdeburg borde but when it
comes to how it is in
let's say in a district of
berlin then we get into areas that are
so small where we are
trying to map the climate change information at the moment
there are challenges and at the
moment when we want to combine
it, i'm happy to pass it
on to astrid with the challenge of
air quality and health aspects, i
think we're
reaching our limits at the moment right,
that's definitely true, i'd
like two  picking up on the examples that were
mentioned earlier in the
projects is one thing  the energy turnaround,
so to speak, the electrification of the
processes that require technologies where,
if in doubt, we don’t know at the moment
firstly which technologies it
will be exactly in which mixture
but secondly also if we
look at hydrogen, for example, what emissions will
these processes and these technologies
have and  what does that
mean for air quality for air chemical
processes compared to our
current
emissions, of which we know very
well
what makes diesel and petrol
emissions small for inner-city air quality,
that means these swings, these
big changes that we will be
confronted with in  of the
future because the entire energy system is being
converted because really every
area of our life will change in the techn
logies that we users in the mater
als that we use in the emiss
ons that go hand in hand with
hem
e have big questions at the moment  r
which means that then potentially for
air quality management and questions how
can we meet the new and
reduced
guide values the world
health organization published this year in or
er to also
rotect the health of the population where
it is the case that air quality is curre
tly the only 1 healt
risk worldwide  environmental reasons
and more than 90 percent of the world's
population live in
[music]
situations in which they are
exposed to
concentration levels that are, so to speak,
well above half of what the
health organizations recommend. ms.
jakob had already addressed the point earlier
that one always has to
work with simplifications  i.e. that
you have to interrupt things and that
sometimes leads to
it being difficult for you to make
statements about very specific areas, for example
, and i personally have the
feeling that this
leads to insecurities
arising for many people d  as then they say he has
everyone saying climate change and everything is getting
warmer and so but now here with me
somehow
22 centimeters of snow suddenly
october and then suddenly such
a model is questioned now
my question would be do you get to
a point where  one would say okay
these models are going to be so good that one can predict
something like that even in such small regions
or
maybe we humans
just have to accept at some point that we cannot
predict everything in advance and that some
things are just partly
coincidences and unpredictable i
think  and to stay with the example
of the 20 centimeters of snow that were
probably
predicted by the weather model but the
climate model didn't predict that 20 years ago for
this region and
you have to distinguish between what is climate and what
is weather
i find this an impressive visualisation
when you think of a climate
the climate of the region you are in  life
that
dictates what kind of selection you have in the wardrobe what
finds what what is there what is there at all
are there winter clothes and
down jackets in there or just swimming shorts
that the climate weather is then what
you pick out and wear on the respective day
and for  keep it reasonable and
that's something it's always going to be that
let's say that the weather is
unpredictable many years from now
in the sense of on 10
october
20.30 you will have this weather there
i would be honest i do
n't even know  it will be different here in the auditorium
don't see any huge added value
i wouldn't derive much for myself in
later life from a special
prediction of course that doesn't really help you, of
course, but
at the same time when you're in the
situation then it suddenly
asks you if you're thinking  also why
couldn't you foresee that
the x will come of course
you can already you can't there  s individual weather
so when you turn 50 i can't tell him it
will rain
or not so that won't work
that will never work but well
until shortly before your birthday but
but we know and that's
different in europe and  in other
countries we now know what kind
of changes we have to expect and
that it is roughly at district level that
's pretty accurate that's
pretty detailed and for many questions
such as design
limits for the design
of waste water dimensioning or
for the building of  cities or in the
area where you have to deal with the fact
that the cities get significantly warmer in
summer and you want to counter this heat island effect,
this heat effect in the cities in
the cities by
bringing more green and blue infrastructure
into the cities, perhaps areas
unsealed that they only do that
if and only if they
have information about it  en that not even in 30 years
such a heat arises, but you
have to reckon with the fact that it now happens every
two years or maybe every year
two or three times and we have this kind of
information in europe all over the place
on a grid of
about 20 30 kilometers
you can map it like berlin, but what i
said, what then happens in every part of the city
, that's the next
point and i think that's
information that is needed for adapting
to climate change to what i've already
changed, that comes again from the
observations  out why this
monitoring is also extremely important and why
we need to strengthen this monitoring system throughout Europe
rather than cut costs, which unfortunately is
done again and again. That is
what you need in order to urban
planners to landscape planners to actually want to check all plans
in life in the
direction of climate change
at the same time  of course they also do
climate protection  ben that means you
have to bring it together now i
think the information is
available i don't think we still have
any chance of saying we
don't know exactly what's happening there is
no data and that's why i'm
not doing anything for now the time is up that was
maybe  ten twelve years ago it was like that
but that's the end of it there are of course
regions on earth
that this information maybe doesn't exist
on this 20 30 kilometer
grid but 50 to 80 but
that's enough for a lot of very, very many
decisions and we know enough
about it that we  immediately
have to do climate protection because otherwise
we will
no longer be able to control the change in weather variability that we are getting worldwide
with pure protective measures we will
no longer be able to protect ourselves from
the extreme precipitation from the
floods for the heat periods
drought storms depending on  where you
look in the world it is n  Of course it's a
little different, but we won't be
able to limit the damage in such a way that it
will cost us a lot of money and it
will also bring a lot of light
with it, which means we have
to adapt to what has already
happened and at the same time and always that
it's also more difficult for
germans
to do things at the same time, also for german research, it's always not
that easy we have to do everything at the same time
from climate protection and if the
adjustments go and take society
with us and learn from what
society knows and that's a big
challenge for them  research, yes, we
have already said we know
that climate change is happening, unfortunately, some people are
still doing it, but i
think the people who are
here in the room right now and who are here to
watch are well aware
that the next logical question is yes,
that  are there any promising
projects where you say okay, there are
devel  sounds maybe they also give
hope and you think okay that's
what if we
push this one second that could really have a
big impact for us
I would maybe go
back
to the changes
we are already dealing with very briefly  just
naming the numbers again
we now live in a 1.1 degree
warmer world than pre
-industrial was the case if we don't act
and emissions continue then
by the end of the century we will be
well over 2 degrees, maybe even 34 degrees
warming up and with every tenth of a
degree further warming up both
the frequency and the intensity
of extreme events that means not
only that the heat waves are becoming more
frequent but the individual heat waves
are also warmer yes and that is of
course also something in the
challenges what how  dealing with
this heat wave, for example
, brings with it its challenges
we have j  now here in the talk no longer
efficiently we don't have
much time to find solutions for that either, so
maybe just a quick question about the
conclusion of this area and we'll
go straight on to other projects as well as
chance we
'll look further into the
Discussion what is happening in climate research, what has to happen,
so again, very briefly,
what kind of projects are there now where you
would say that creates hope,
so they will say okay, that's what, that
will have an impact for us, around us
to move forward in the fight against
climate change
i would actually say almost
all projects in the area of
e change and adaptation to the conse
uences of climate change are currently expos
d there are very many good
xamples there are if you look
ationally this example database at th
Federal Environment Agency there  Europe-wide there are
these examples of how you can adapt
, but also how you can change the climate  how to
avoid greenhouse gas emissions
also at the ea of the european war metal agenc
there are many research projects in th
field of the joint programming initi
tive climate there are very many
ood networks and i think what
will focus
on in the future are the eu  mission these new
instruments we can
perhaps talk about them again later, condense the
knowledge we have from research
and, above all,
bring it into the solution space and
implement it so that the region and
then ultimately the whole of europe is
more sustainable climate resilient  and it's
fair it's a
wonderful cliffhanger i think we
'll come back to that
in a moment now we're going back to a project because
one thing that is of course total is that
we've heard a lot that
when we talk about what we're doing
if we want to make
solutions then of course we have to solve the
problem  tehen and the topic of
greenhouse gases is very very important
and co2 knows many methane is
still somehow understood by many but there is
really a great understanding for
it i often
don’t know in society what is very
abstract is what is what you
don’t somehow directly  looks like
water, for example, that was there before and
then somehow dried up and
that’s why it’s all the more important that
you take a closer look and that’s
what the next project is about and
now we’ve brought in two researchers from the
major project hello mister bremer and
minister we think  daily time to talk
about the product of the award is
a well-known pocket models
android data competition
the integrated
content management
world
trade
center is technology
in change research
[music]
the
constellation is the business location
is
the ewz integrated product suite of
domains worth somewhere else must here  as
active guests
seemed the atmosphere  re to
[music]
manage
real time data
station des nations
[music]
league
enl
[music]
missions rising
waters
is the uci exchangers is country
weekend changes for example
power plant from
power plant solar energy days in
Jordanian
[music]
hotspot two people
[Music]
mister cash in for you because many
countries and
justice
than the
trade and
the head so
now let yourself off the grill and a
21 already practice and theory and practice
atmosphere concentration so jacob
germany nations work together
easily
reimbursed support and
country is in your work together teeth
less
room
for improvement
okay so cool is coming back
but like to
improve the man's right from the cops
so exchange topic what is coming up
change the end with
reference to
the herforder
what people
extended
course for success
the session is
because of the  people to the monastery to
relocation
henkel much for the information
directly from the get and such nonsense
the in  formation about
the
talking about this project fonds linhart
finanzformel project
project it will be very special because
it's about climate change and action
nike hears we have to be course clear with
is changing world
weekly effekts at the next project is
about and i'm happy alexander meier  is
so popular here everything is different
project natal
the
changing active
what happens to be 8x the fund is
that the in the stations buy
mum how you eat at all from
post is preventively loose and the reason
for the consequences are on the art in the
optics
of the
-86 settlement euro
cost on such public
favorite provider for electricity so that the transport
is immensely
impact
x86 infrastructure and leipzig west
an industrial air in it to whose
villa
keltenfest course as an integrated system
so
people that is a malicious form and
you can discipline the defender's slogan
of cross
course to more active systems
online platform and that
- as on  seems another course
last but least is that this is with
people living on discourse and in mexico
medak the midfield side that
means is a brisk minute next
chunk i thought
the project is at the alfred wegner
institute in potsdam is designed
double dip
the  bull terrier so
the new carrier command
others beijing can
get into bed or two old maurice
that is in
london
it is all so sloppy it even dual
use high logic express
an allocation bullfight before
it is
explained by one of the
almost everything is
so easy
experience is a  editorial team
of
climate change
heard in the morning that at the festival
of climate change research a
journalist is often disrespectful the
wind evidently have before he
on the portobello to the arctic 1400 often for
a
babysitter this long drink los angeles
the
transformation
general
motors is a little one  change body
almost
all technical tactical curl context
lin  k to people's experience is a live
that is investing in the war
because here the sensation is
maybe okay too the first cache and
cosmology discuss the question what i
like it optimally on the province the talk
about the perception that
i have to
[music]
climate change  to be able to do something new
there is that of the arrested typical
technology solution
if the
technology to give euros to the side
transformation but that trusted how
great point and access point into the
discussion so tanke very much for
information and
so we have talked about permafrost
here but also about  the
topic of adaptation to climate change was
discussed we also talked about the topic of
perception and
one of the points was that there
's a lot going on here too that it
's not just musical it's
not just about chemistry  the
composition of any gases
or something but it's just very
broad now would be my fr  age
is what you also notice
that this
topic is so broad and also this social aspect that
is what you keep encountering
in your research jakob is
definitely definitely so i think
that's what we do too  in
climate research over the last i would
say ten and fifteen years have also
correctly understood that there are
these different areas there is
one we wanted to understand the natural
climate system that you
need climate research to understand
what what how the air currents the
ocean currents change under
various boundary conditions, such
as the change in the
composition of the atmosphere, i.e.
through greenhouse gases, the second thing is
that it became increasingly clear that
people can
not be left out of the picture, people cannot be left
out as the cause or of
changes, but also as those affected
and  I believe in the last one  in
four five years where the change
and where the climate change has
progressed so far worldwide and also in
europe also in germany it has progressed so far
that actually everyone can notice
that something has changed when you
resign britons with your grandmother and
say we were  because the weather is always like this in may,
then it is suddenly
different today and i think
that was when it became clear that if
we look at climate change,
then we have to look at the entire system,
and of course we need this in
research in particular  the
exchange with the social and
human sciences and beyond the
pure natural sciences, the
systemic ones, which she also presented very
nicely, the
research with art and cultural sciences,
everything that belongs to it, everything is a
system in which we all are,
we have that very well  understood because I think
the challenge is so big
that  we definitely have to learn from the
experiences that have been accumulated over the last few centuries,
so there have always been
challenges dealing with
extreme weather events and who
did it, what can you
learn there and i think that was very, very
well understood and  That means
learning from history on the one
hand and on the other hand, of
course, learning from other
regions across borders,
that also means that in our current situation we can
also learn for the
future if, for example, we get
warmer from regions that maybe now
are already affected by it
so i can exchange ideas i
think and then we can talk to
you right away and i think we
have to we have to talk to each other
i can certainly
learn things but of course it is
the context in which you find yourself
often another so very clear
example there is a very, very, very long time
already arid management strategies in
spain we don't have a perfectly
well thought out arid strategy for
management in germany
but it would probably
look a bit different than the one in spain but of
course there are
similar similar conditions where we would
now say okay we
don't have that at all  many dry
ones didn't have to deal with it that much
but now they are here and there is
also a lot of experience with a
lot of research in this area at the moment
that's just a small example
but I think this exchange is
important too  looking at the
past wars is a very exciting point
important but we would like to go back to it now
but i actually find
the question interesting because
then it suddenly becomes so concrete
what kind of learning is that you could
then take over from spain, for example
but maybe you know maybe
you can connect that yes ma can  n
certainly connect i have my
doubts that we learn it from the
experiences of others in particular i believe
that societies
as, so to speak,
only know it happens acting
units should not
really be seen if that were the case and
if you were just learning from facts
then we must now too
If we hadn’t dealt with climate change, then in the 1990s we would have
drawn conclusions
from what was already known from the models and from
climate research at the
time and we would
n’t have to deal with an atmosphere with more than 400
ppm
co2, so in that sense we didn’t
have to  I am not very
confident that one should only draw the conclusion from
statements about the existence of knowledge
that
societies necessarily
learn from it and always
draw the conclusion that avoidance is
in the foreground can also give other
values and considerations which then do no
admit  lead to an avoidance
that is one thing i would like to take up again
and what i really believe is
an element in which
european research also stands out internationally
that
has already been said before but it became clear again using the example
of lycos is really
this  element
research infrastructures to advance and continue to advance the observation of the environment
not to stop saying
alright we have a coherent series of
data and and we can then
look at what has changed once a year
but also really make
progress to
ensure that, if possible, we
take the data, so to speak, when  eat da then
also make the data available
so that in case of doubt
they can be adopted for any forecast models an example of this
is that this is a european
infrastructure where
measurements of climate variables are
made on board airliners where, for example  the data is also made available in
real time, for example profiles
of airports with every take-off and
landing, a profile of the atmosphere is recorded, so to speak
, which you
can hardly record in any other way, which is used,
for example, in the models of the
european center for medium-term
weather
forecasts in order to improve it  to
bring about the models and there are
really great
things to be internationally visible on the front line and to
push things forward that just ten
years ago did not seem possible at all,
that means we are in a certain
pioneering role and above all  we also
show okay we can collect this
information together a lot more
information and
also make this information accessible
you also have a certain
role model function which you may also
notice that there is a change in
thinking that europe is
opening up and with it other d  ann
pull along as far as this
freedom of data is concerned, for example, that you make it available
to a person
definitely so at jagos, for example
, it is always the case that the infrastructure has existed for
20 years and has made
data freely available from the start,
so you have to register  say what
you want to do with the data
but you can register there as a private person
and get access to the data and
this concept of making data that you have
obtained for science available in such a way
that others can also
use it for their
own research  and
really using public funds in a certain way in such a
way that the efficient
ones can continue to be used is something
europe has a major role to play in
promoting this view of openness freedom
of access to
information and i also believe that
the exchange within  europe and
science is in her k
I would say more
content and question-driven,
and we do science because we
want to solve something because
we are interested in a question so
that borders and, so to speak, origin of
national origin do not
really play a major role or what could be transferred
much further from
research
i think that's very good in many other areas, but of course we
also have that that does
n't just sound good that's of course good and
with the climate problem you
can of course also have a problem that
affects everyone, which means at the end of the
day yes  also interested somewhere
that there is a solution and
at the same time you can see that there are
differences in the countries, also
as far as behavior is concerned i can
already see myself taking a critical look
from mrs jakob maybe i assume
that if the thinking is the same
stop
countries behave differently
even with this knowledge  there is
climate change is what
where research should
maybe push politics even more in these countries
or how do
possible solutions look
like i think right what what said as a third party
is definitely these to
act more freely in the research framework across
europe  and subject-driven
curiosity-driven whatever you
want to call it and i think that
is an extremely good example of how you
can exchange ideas across borders,
how you can make progress together
and how you can also learn
to absorb and accept the perspectives of others and that's
it  we argue
we come to an agreement again we find
common solutions but
europe is also very good right now
due to the many regions this regional diversity due to the
many states i think very
very interesting because you
look at questions again or are made
aware of one  completely
different point of view
in the moment where it  the
implementation is about the end of data
freedom as nice as
you just described it here, but if it is
about that i need the data to
dimension my
adaptation measures
then the data is no longer
all freely accessible then it has to be  you
pay for data or you have to
pay for neighboring services
i can understand that if i want to
have the data specially evaluated now
that you pay for
everything to be added but we don’t have
such transparent usable
data freedom in europe as soon as we leave  come
into application in the research area
and then we also have
a lot of industry-driven research
in europe and that too is of course
not connected to the research driven by let’s say the
national or european
research program
as it could actually be
because we have there  there are still barriers
and I think we have to have these barriers
over we don't have a chance
we live in this changing climate
we need the great transformation
we need to conserve resources we
have the chance to generate a whole new
age you now have
the chance sometimes i don't want to where
not honestly i'm old and i am
no longer actually able to
pave the way for a whole new era of
innovative, sustainable, climate-resilient and
fair
we now have the time
to change this dynamic and to say let's design
something different than we were before the
industrial ones we didn't know
what to do with  industrialization does
everything good and bad but
now we have completely different
possibilities through research and through
communication and when we consider
that we are faced with questions it just occurred to me
soon we are also
faced with questions in europe
let's relocate an entire
coastal town we're doing  because what
do we have to do if we are a
coastal city from climate  reasons for the change move
30 kilometers
inland that sounds a
bit like it ok we are were so we
are very good at sharing the data first
if there are changes to
be determined ok there is no one what
does he look like what are the changes
in the application  if it then becomes
more difficult it may also be
that we have the one success we
have already done that this
data is exchanged and now the
challenge for the future and
these are the steps that have to
be taken for a change that you have to
get there  that there is even more cooperation in the area of
ation at Europ
an level, so I think we defin
tely need this type of resea
ch or this research cooperation and basic research to continue. I ab
s
lutely believe we have
o get much better and some people in Eu
ope are already better than we are in Germa
y  the knowledge will be in
the applications  to bring implementation
so not only to prepare for the application
but also then to implement
and that's where we need politics
that research can no longer
do on its own that means we actually need
a
more lively dialogue between research
and politics when it comes to possible
solutions either  develop them
together to test their side effects
because not every solution is good from the
outset some you
have to discard again and then
implement them and i think that is
a social challenge
that is needed across borders
now in and we in europe
could actually
live very nicely in this european research area
these are steps that are probably
pending now and that brings
us to the last topic block in the
end, namely the outlook and
there we have another connection,
namely marc lorenz is now connected
live from the event
and it  becomes a b  it's about that, yes,
what can the future look like, so
what are the big challenges that
are affecting us right now, what steps do we have to
take now to make progress
marc lorenz is director of the institute
for advanced sustainability in potsdam
and he deals a lot with the
topic  yes what are the big
challenges the challenges we have to
tackle
rock pop
event
the internet
of
things
change
[music]
we have
done let's switch to the german
mr lorenz thank
you very much that you like to talk to us what are they
big challenges of the next
ten years
and what are the steps we have to take now
yes then
i can say stormy greetings from glasgow again today the
weather is terrible and
maybe you are in the
mood to play games because one of the boss machines is
on the road today and  these are not
nice weather activists but they
really seriously m  one around
the head negotiations around a
bit as a listener can to show
how important it is what is happening here
, namely
there it is the transformations we
need to get started fast enough to
reduce the emissions of co2 and
other climate drivers like
we now have to halve methane by 20 30
animals that means for co2 and
about to have a chance at
all the parisians communicate a
home and we have to do that if
we really respect for what's behind
me first yes the really big globe the
many  seen on tv and
if we really have respect for it
and that's complex we need five
courses so turn to an energy
turnaround a mobility turnaround a food walls
and more relaxed agricultural turnaround an action
if a construct if production
together with industry that's not easy
and have this complexity  my
colleagues hustvedt and daniela already
mentioned references at the very beginning de  r
and district league are interdisciplinary
and allow international
cooperation and of course there
is the European research area. The whole
course will be a question and if we were to think about it, we
should first focus on it
. I think the
phase-out of coal in Europe is one that we should
definitely tackle quickly, but I
welcome it  the initiative of the
governmental formations in
germany that they could possibly
phase out of coal by 20:30 and
that must be replaced by renewables
not by nuclear power if
we really seriously
want to just jump worldwide and secondly we
need a major course on
mobility in europe and
electrification  a big one of but
there are a lot more mega markets there
if you look at it now so
a lot of innovations have already been
mentioned renewable energies but
also the mobility turnaround towards
electric cars if we
pursue this innovation un  d
perhaps give these developments even more
speed you can't make a forecast of what it will be
like in ten years
will we manage
to stop climate change slow it down
what you think will happen
well like daniela said with climate models you can
hardly ever make predictions with
computer models  and you like
him when that happens then that happens
and i i my personal prediction
is that we will
really make very, very difficult
progress in the next ten years
but it really depends on many
factors how the course grows and how the young people
move  Renewable energy is actually
gaining momentum, to what extent can we get other countries that are a
little reluctant
to give in to these negotiations and
so on, what I can say at the
moment is
that the findings are promising worldwide when they
are added together, as you
probably know, they come to a
conclusion  that we in all
probability  our mission stays
about the same until 8.30 p.m. and when
that happens we can already see over
the 15 degree mark and we
had to accelerate the editing of
emissions even faster from the
legal ones we’ve been there in the last few
years martin
you’ve already addressed
her
do you have the idea of having a chance or ti
e to stay so i see
that the prognosis is bleak
unless really all the effor
s on the market will actually come toget
er and set us on the path
o reducing emissions you h
ve already mentioned man
must work with the countries, some of
which also refuse to
change and there is of course a
big question what is the role of
europe. we can assume a pioneering
role
we
could have
absolutely so europe and if it
you  n if now nonsense through which it is
really important who
or has to take on a
pioneering role in which, so to speak, a
train was running and we had to be in
all of the five that I mentioned
earlier one from two games in
renewable energies we have the
potential  actually have a good
enough
livelihood in that we
could actually do that if it was
important to us
to switch almost entirely to renewable energies in the next 10 15 years
to export these renewable
energies and bring them to other countries with great
support and
secondly as an example  mobility if we
need concepts for a
holistic mobility donation i.e.
electrification of cars but not
only that and if a really a
complete if the temple
education concept and then of course the
really big effort there leading the
rhetoric in in europe is the annoyance me
so if we  our green new deal  and
so on look at the question therefore in
English is
really there invest in our
big
special guest and then north mouse at the
head
rose sentence is the ambitions in you
understand right now he is very
bad unfortunately the manager with again
to raise or repair hear with
me  so try that as far as i
should but can stand maybe
we say goodbye to
mr lorenz it's a pity that
it's breaking off like this but yes the
internet connection doesn't seem
to be good unfortunately but i find something you can
definitely take out of here  is
that on the one hand piece will have
this gloomy forecast so if things
continue like this then a full can will
race against the wall and on the other
hand what i thought was really nice there was
also a small glimmer of hope that
europe has the opportunity
to take on a leadership role  and with that
maybe also to
strive for changes because the possibilities are
the innov  ation the the technologies that
are at least to be shared already there that
is the statement from mr lorenz as
i understood it now my
question would be would you sign that or
do you think that there might be
more aspects
that need to be considered everyone knows no longer
wants to start  I know well let's start
I think it's already
evident that
from promises of reducing
greenhouse
gases in the relatively distant future we still
don't add any value to animals I
always like to say because the sentence my
goal without a plan is just a wish that
means that  it will really be relevant and important in the next few
years to break
these goals
down into individual actions
what does that mean in the most diverse
areas of our lives
i think it is also important and
necessary to emphasize that such
changes are not just a
threatening scenario and that
something is changing  but there is
also a chance in there  the
chance on the one hand to negotiate works again
and to really make
sure that we make the right
emphasis in society
but there are also
economic opportunities if you are a
technology driver and things are, so to
speak, the first to be developed
or at the forefront  when it comes to development,
then of course it is the case when you
develop economic concepts
that can also open up a large global
market, you
have to see that and
not just have
it in your head, so to speak, that it could be
something threatening something at the expense of
something else  that means there
is also a certain chance for
us to profit from it in the end and to be a
bit of a winner at the end of the day thanks to this pioneering role,
or
so i think we are all winners, especially if
climate protection is applied
globally  but now of
course as if European  a
wants to take on a pioneering role,
so i
don’t like to talk about whether
europe has a pioneering role or
not i don’t think europe doesn’t have one at the
moment either
, maybe it could have but i
don’t really think that europe has an
absolute pioneering role i think
so  but also it doesn't matter who has the
pioneering role i think they all
have to go and who is the first to start now
you can't wait for that you can
also so that's a bit of a
problem i don't like this discussion
that much we have we have one in
europe  Pioneers and I believe that Europe
must do everything it can, regardless of whether you
want to play a pioneering role or not
. All the forces that are available in
Europe must
be used to shape this change sensibly,
and whether someone else in the world is
also starting to do that
maybe trigger a bit of enthusiasm
and cause you to run a little
faster like I have ke  in
problem with but i think
you shouldn't look after that i think that
we need this cooperation and there
are many others who are also on the
way so it's not only like that in
europe and if i look at it
, when and where does bayern fly to
in in in the news
about where you can fly to glasgow and then to which
restaurant and then have dinner in the evening
then i have to
ask myself whether europe can really
talk about the pioneering role but it's not
really about that
i think you have to have the potential
use what europe has and and i would
like to get back to this
research area i
agree with brokers is of course complete
and astrid also exactly with the chances
you have of course it is like that we
have some european countries such
as the netherlands which are much
more efficient and
move faster in converting research results into sellable export hits than we do  what has been done
in germany in the last decades
, we had long
discussions about key technologies
in germany and didn't get that far
, so you
can then also look at the differences in europe,
but if we look at the
european research area,
then i think we have it  the
capacities and the
possibilities to get several things off the ground at the same time
and that is
what we need and that is
perhaps what distinguishes europe as
a unique selling point, so to speak, and
then perhaps also brings a pioneering role
because i think we have to do that
exactly  what astrid said at the beginning
we have to see where are the
side effects of the energy transition,
for example with the energy transition what
happens what actually happens with the
new drive options where are
the five levers that the brand says the
big walls that we need they
will be too  all side effects  n have
positives and negatives and we have to deal with that together
in European research
now and we wo
n't be able to just keep the 1.5 degrees
and not shoot over it,
that means even if we
go back to 15 degrees somewhere later
settle down or somewhere between 1.5
and 2 degrees at the moment we
are still on the way until the beginning of last
week we were at 27 at the moment it is a
bit easy to do so that wasn’t so
bad this first week
we’ll wait and see  the second week
might deliver, we are at 23
or something in the end in the projections
at the moment, i think, but we also have
to deal with research about
which technologies
we need, how can we, so to
speak, strengthen these natural co2 reductions
and how can we strengthen
them  create social upheaval
together because what was
said before health air quality
climate change health that will be
be a challenge and i
think you can really go ahead
in the research area and
then maybe show something in that area if you
do everything at once you can
still make it are not very
nice words so for me i can
definitely of  this evening here
take away afternoon meanwhile
that there are a lot of
possibilities that there are a lot of
chances that we have the
opportunity to change things and that that would do us very,
very well because it is simply a
super relevant topic and
what you find so beautiful  yes, you could see here
that there is already a lot of
cooperation in all the different projects, the european
garden, a lot is happening and in the end
the conclusion is what you can wear a
bit, especially in the field of
research, it's great what's
happening, but more can
happen  and that's always good
when more can happen because then it's
over again  room for improvement and i think
that's what i'll definitely
take with me, so we
actually need more research together
, especially when it comes to concrete solutions
, we have to work
together more and i'll take that with me today
and i think it's a really
nice one  matter because we are now here
at the balance 1 away is a
future talk project from the bmbf and next
year is also the science year 2022
with the big topic okay we
want to create research together
and we want to do research together so
society together with research
wants to ask questions  develop that
can then be worked on and I think
that is something that complements very
well what we have seen today, the
whole topic, i.e. the topic of climate change,
climate protection,
but also a lot of other topics
that are so multi-perspective that
you really can’t even look at them  enough
perspectives can look at it and
that's why I think it's totally to  ll on
the one hand this day here because me
and he brought a lot of information
to light again and also to a
certain extent i know there were also many gloomy moments hamann to a certain extent i
think it also gave hope
and at the same time i think that these
development with the science year
2022 there is also a
nice example in a way, a nice
encouragement that I will definitely
take with me for myself that we simply
do more research work
together even more instead of against each other and
I would say that in the end it is
also a very nice one  Conclusion for the ff
user day and I would like to say a big
thank you to both of them, to
everyone who
tuned in and of course to all the
people behind the scenes who did
everything here in Zurich. I thought it
was a very, very exciting evening and
also many thanks to the people who
watched who were here on site
I think it is  t really it's such an
important topic and that's great when
we deal with it a lot
you can't say it often enough
thank you very much thank you very much i think
[applause]
[music]